yo bootleg cat podcast man Hartford
Connecticut's in the building yeah Fuego
base is in the building yeah it's about
time let's get to it big BSF hey man he
pulled up he said I'm gonna just bring
the double clip ready to go let's get to
it come on waiting to do this come on
man
[Music]
sir it's a pleasure to be here
um
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
no ambition and reaching for nothing
it's like Martin Luther did all that
pizza for nothing our minds are a weapon
that we loading up if Malcolm was alive
he'll roll with us God's mission for me
ain't burning proof I'm here to lead you
[__] like some Journey
okay okay okay okay
come on
let's do another ones let's do another
one
let's get it
all right
yeah let's get back into this [__] man
keep going keep going
to the bush man
yeah I mean bootleg cab once again thank
you for having me I can't even rap let's
turn up yeah yeah
have fun with this [__]
everything
[Music]
y'all gonna get to know me today
cause I was in the front lines like B
Davis
[Music]
like my raps
[__] whoa
biggest
Fuego base
come on man go through it go go go get
some water go get some water get out of
here get out of here the bike's on fire
I appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle is on the
way presented by LRG